hello everyone uh welcome to another
episode of q a about the future of
Science and Technology
um I had a gap for a couple of sessions
here I was uh away
but I'm back now
all right
question here
uh
about from deaths would an alien
intelligence experiencing a different
slice of the rouliad
a
roster I don't know quite what that
means close to ours likely experience
black holes in a similar way
that's an interesting question all right
so let's set some some framework for
this
so
one of the big sort of the deepest part
of the rabbit hole that came from our
physics project is this object we call
the rouliad
and if we start thinking about how do we
Define what's happening in physics
one of the implications of our physics
project is there's ultimately a
computational rule that when run for
long enough reproduces everything that
happens in our universe
but then the question is why one rule
and not another and so what we realized
is well actually one can think about the
universe as running all possible rules
and that's represented by this thing we
call the rouliad where you start from
all possible initial conditions and
you're running all possible
computational rules and you're seeing
all the possible consequences and the
and the key fact is that even when there
are sort of two separate states that are
generated by different rules those two
states can converge again because when
they each have the appropriate rules
applied to them they could kind of
collide and end up producing the same
state further on so this really ad
object has if you trace some of the
states and this really the evolution of
states and there's really an object
you'll see a bunch of branching and a
bunch of merging it's a very complicated
kind of assembly of things
so
the thing that um uh so that that's the
ruling ad object now the key point is
that we are somehow embedded in this
rule out object so we experience the
universe our perception of what's going
on in the universe is based on us
sampling sort of our piece of the
rouliad that represents us sampling the
ruling ad so to speak
and each of us each kind of mind in a
sense has some internal collection of
states that it sort of that are its
experience as defined as a part of the
rouliad and different Minds have
different sequences of states that they
experience because in a sense different
minds are at different places in the
rouliad different minds are different
places in real space and so even between
different human Minds we're all at
different places in real space so if you
were to look at the even at the sort of
individual nerve firings inside our
brains they'd in detail be different the
thing that is surprising and remarkable
is that there's enough sort of
commonality that we can communicate talk
about sort of shared experiences and so
on even though the details of what's
Happening inside our brains is different
from each of us
and there's this kind of idea that there
is this communication process this fact
that we can use language for example we
can package up those detailed sort of
internal thoughts that we have into
Concepts that we can represent for
example as words and we can then take
one of those words communicate them to
somebody else they can unpack that word
into their own internal kind of neural
firings and so on so this idea and I've
talked about this before this this idea
that kind of concepts are the thing that
you can transport from one place in
Royal space to another part Concepts I
think are like particles in physical
space like things like electrons
represent some way that you can
communicate stuff you can think of it as
information from one place in the
universe to another and sort of have
something kind of propagate without
change have kind of pure emotion from
one place to another and I think that's
what's kind of happening in rural space
with with Concepts and words and so on
so now the question is what would be in
common in the experiences of Minds at
different places in real space observers
at different places in a rural space
potentially there are between different
sort of you can you can kind of measure
the distance in real space it's kind of
how aligned are the concepts how much
translation is necessary to go from one
set of internal states of one mind to
the internal states of another so for
example between different humans as well
depending on how similar the kind of
educational cultural et cetera
backgrounds are that it can be quite
close or much further away in real space
when we go to things like animals we're
further away in real space we can have
some sort of emotional kind of
connection to the animals that's
something that that isn't described so
much in words but it's described in a
kind of a universal language of emotion
so to speak of you know whether it's the
uh the human facial expressions or the
dog facial expressions we don't have
tails to wag but um at least the facial
expressions have kind of a uh uh kind of
significant commonality between humans
and for example well the mammals and so
on
um actually it's an interesting question
whether that facial expression
commonality extends Beyond mammals I I
don't know I've I've not I haven't seen
a lot of facial expression on the on the
part of lizards let's say
um uh or certainly you know Charles
Darwin in fact had a had a um
uh in a book I think expression emotions
and animals and man
um was one of his last Publications in
which he was trying to trace this
commonality I think only from mammals
now that I think about it but any case
so it's kind of further in real space to
get to a fish
um but uh uh now the question is are
there Concepts which all of those sort
of Critters all of those Minds agree on
interesting question
um and you know are black holes for
example a concept now your average
person hasn't encountered a black hole
perhaps fortunately your average fish
has definitely not encountered a black
hole
so the question is is there some feature
hmm
you know I think
ordinary okay so what is a black hole
black hole is a place where sort of
information can go in but can't come out
that has an event horizon where kind of
all those things whether they're
particles Concepts whatever else they
can go in but they can't come out you're
you're as as we look at the sort of time
evolution of a black hole things are
falling into the black hole but not
coming out of the black hole there's
there's kind of irreversible kind of
falling in but not coming out so to
speak that's happening now it gets more
subtle when you go into quantum gravity
and so on but let's not go there for
right now
so
in the in our models the case of a
physical Black Hole uh in is something
we can see in the causal graph of
space-time so causal graph is there are
lots of Elementary events that are
happening and in our models these are
rewrite rules for the hypergraphs that
represent the the state of the universe
that all these rewrites happening and we
can say what is the what are the causal
connections between these rewrite events
so for example one rewrite event might
require that other reward events have
already happened where it doesn't have
the inputs that it needs for that next
Blue ride event to occur so there's this
causal graph that represents the causal
connections between all the rewrite
events and what's happening in a black
hole is that there's a region of the
graph of space where there are causal
edges that are going into that region
there's causation from the outside to
the inside but there's no causal edges
coming out from the inside of a black
hole to the outside so that's kind of
the definition of a black hole and that
in the case of physical space we're just
imagining there's this region in a
physical space okay so now we can get
more exotic with branchial space the
space of quantum branches but right now
let's talk about rule space and we can
talk about sort of a black hole in real
space well you can talk about the
perception of an ordinary black hole hmm
uh let me think about that for a second
I do suspect
let me think about that for a second
no it's a little bit more complicated
because
the way the black hole was produced the
way the causal graph is produced depends
on the rules that you're using for
describing the universe
so if you'll use different rules you
will get a different causal graph
and you will get different structure of
the black hole that even happens in the
case of quantum mechanics you take kind
of different branches of History you can
get different structures for the black
hole and that can lead you to all kinds
of issues that show up as sort of
paradoxes and traditional quantum
mechanics meeting gravitation Theory and
so on so I think it isn't the case that
that the sort of the black hole is a
constant across different from from
different points in real space you might
perceive a black hole differently so I
don't think that there's any particular
necessary commonality between what
what's a black hole to one sort of Mind
might not be a black hole to another
mind because in a sense they are
describing the universe differently and
that means that they have a different
set of events that they're thinking
happens so to speak in the universe so I
think I think there isn't commonality
there now an interesting question is
what's the aloe of a black hole in real
space
that's a place where one can kind of uh
over the course of time there are sort
of
in a sense
um
one
one is sort of having this this these
Concepts that go in but don't come out
somehow that's kind of the analog of uh
yeah that's kind of the analog of um of
a black hole where you know particles
fall into the black hole but don't come
out so in the case of Royal space What
will be happening is Concepts will be
going into that region of real space but
won't be coming out
and I think that is
corresponds to uh in mathematics that
would correspond to a decidable theory
one where kind of in the end any
question you ask has a definite answer
and just say boom we've answered the
question we're done as opposed to
something where there are undecidable
propositions where you can be sort of
trying to prove what's happening and
there's an infinite path that's kind of
the analog of you could be wandering
around in physical space for an infinite
time or you can be sort of uh trapped
inside the eventualizing or black hole
and time is of limited duration for you
and eventually you get sort of crushed
of the singularity of the black hole so
in a sense the analog in Royal space is
is it something where you can sort of
answer every question or is it something
where you keep on having sort of uh
where you whether you keep on having to
wonder what the answer to the questions
is so in a sense it's kind of a thing
where there's an area of knowledge we
can just say this area of knowledge is
finished you know everything you might
ask about this area of knowledge boom
you can get the answer as opposed to
this is something where you have to keep
trying to work things out and it's kind
of a computational irreducible process
but we say I wonder what happens in this
case I wonder what happens if we go
further I wonder what happens if we go
further the kind of rule black hole is
the place where sort of knowledge is
finished in that in that area in that
way of thinking about the world that
sort of region of knowledge is is all
worked out there's nothing more to say
that sort of time ends for that type of
knowledge I think that's the kind of the
analog of this in real space a bit
abstract I have to say this is um
This is complicated
uh
um let's see let me just take a few of
these later questions that just came in
and then let me come back to some other
things and say so Brady asks is real
space bigger than branchial space yes
much much much bigger
so branchial space is what happens when
you have these typographs and you're
rewriting things and there are different
possible parts of rewriting with a given
rule rule your space is you look at all
possible rules and so that is vastly
bigger like like one might be I don't
know 10 to the in our universe might be
you know of size the number of quantum
branches might be maybe
I don't know I had an estimate of maybe
10 to the 120 but I'm not sure if it's
right might be much larger than that but
compared to that the size of allele
space is more like 10 to the 10 to the
500.
so unbelievably exponentially larger and
it is amazing what a small fraction of
real space we have explored you know I
looked at this thing with generative AI
what one's looking at uh what of of the
possible things that one can generate
regenerative Ai and that's generative AI
that's already been trained from things
like human images There Are Places
instead of the space of possible things
you can generate that correspond to
recognizable things like cats and dogs
and there's a huge interconcept space
and even in a rather simple case I was
looking at the region of interconcept
space so to speak analogous Interstellar
space I suppose the region of
interconcept space that we have so far
explored that we so far have words for
have a description in our language is 10
to the minus 600. so we have explored an
absolutely microscopic fraction of the
space of all classical Concepts and
that's just Concepts which are kind of
derived from things that come from
pictures that we put on the web so when
we go beyond that it's probably more
like 10 to the 10 to the 500 10 to the
10 to the 600 something like this and we
have you know it's it's uh 10 to the
minus 10 to the 600 or something that's
the fraction of the rouliad that we have
so far explored so there's there's a lot
more about sort of how we might
experience the universe that we could
explore but we have not at this time
um
so don comments maybe it's a gaussian
distribution around a point in Royal
space that makes human Minds I mean
human Minds
are
we all have a certain
in a sense diversity of points of view
we are not requiring we have a certain
uncertainty about the rules of the
universe and we operate with certain
with a certain amount of uncertainty
about the rules of the universe and
that's kind of our extent in real space
is that uncertainty see what one of the
things one could think about is one of
the key ideas in science is the idea of
scientific conduction the idea once
you've seen certain things happen can
you deduce that other things will happen
in a certain way can you take a certain
amount of evidence and derive from that
a definite law of the universe which you
can then apply in the future so in a
sense our extent in rural space
gives a sense of the extent to which we
can't figure out we have only as limited
amount of information to figure out the
laws of the universe and we are
uncertain to some extent about the laws
of the universe we don't have as much
data as we need to be able to nail down
it's got to be this slower not another
and in a sense if we could we could be
sort of infinitesimally small points in
real space we will be nailing down it's
this law for the universe and not others
so in a sense our our fuzziness in real
space is an ultimate limit on the
process of scientific induction
I mean that's a fairly complicated uh
sort of way of thinking about it but
that's that's kind of a way to think
about it and and this whole question
about sort of how extended are we in
these different kinds of space it's kind
of an interesting thing in physical
space you know the universe is 10 to the
26 meters across we are give or take a
meter tool
and the elementary length the shortest
possible distance the size of of
elements of the hypergraph might be 10
to the minus 100 meters then the minus
80 meters I don't know those are only
very rough estimates but that means that
we are pretty big compared to the atoms
of space so to speak we're pretty big
compared to the elementary lengths
relative to the size of the universe so
it might be 80 orders of magnitude below
us and 26 orders of magnitude above us
so we're pretty big in that in that
respect
in bronchial space I don't know exactly
how big we are the extent to which we
are our size in branchial space
characterizes the extent to which we
don't see quantum mechanics in the sense
that the Boer and branchial space the
more we are sort of averaging out things
out and we don't see kind of the weird
effects of quantum mechanics so in a
sense I think the observation of quantum
mechanics it limits our size and
branchial space
but I think in rural space so I don't
know how big we are in Brownfield space
I've done a few estimates of this but I
don't really know the answer to that
um in in rural space we're really really
tiny I mean our our minds extend very
not very far at all in real space
and and so that it's kind of like
there's there's a certain distance we've
got to explore with our spacecraft so to
speak we're not going to get to the edge
of the universe because that would take
the lifetime of the universe to get to
but we're not going to get that far but
you know we could send out spacecraft
but there's much less far to go than
there is distance to go in the rouliad
exploring sort of different paradigms so
in a sense you know if we say are we
going to build spacecraft and go out
into space or are we going to sort of
explore the purely intellectual
paradigms there's vastly more to explore
in sort of the purely intellectual
paradigms than there is in looking at
pieces of physical space
all right let's see
uh
well I've got uh many questions here
right I'll take one that just came in
from Harry uh what do you think about
NASA's recently released plans to build
a moon-based radio telescope uh I've
been kind of hearing about this for ages
but
you know if you put a telescope on The
Far Side of the Moon then doesn't have
any radio interference from the earth
and that's a good thing I mean right now
that places like you know Green Bank
West Virginia where you know cell phones
are banned and that gives the radio
telescope a better chance to operate but
basically right now on the earth it's
just full of radio energy that we're
using for all kinds of communications
kinds of mechanisms and uh I think that
the um
um the thing that um
uh is is certainly going to be the case
as we get to 5G telecommunications
things like this it's really quite
inefficient if you're trying to
communicate from device a to device B
and you do that by having kind of radio
energy go out in all directions from the
device saying just some of those
directions happen to reach device B
that's kind of an inefficient way to do
things and in a sort of perfect world
and that's what's getting closer in 5G
one is kind of arranging the radio
energy so that it's actually
concentrated more in some kind of beam
that gets to the device one's trying to
get to if that continues then what and
once really instead of having you know
in the first approximation you can
communicate by sending data through
wires where there's a definite wire and
it goes to that copper wire it goes to
the fiber a piece of fiber optics never
gets out of the wire but now in free
space when you're using radio
communication for example the the most
generic way to do that is to have an
antenna that basically puts energy out
in all directions and then the device
that's picking it up picks up just the
tiny fraction of that energy that
happens to go in its direction now as
you make phased arrays for example where
you have many different antennas and
they're they're produced radio energy
with different phase relationships so
that you kind of form the beam so it
goes in a particular direction then you
can have something much more efficient
until eventually you're at the point
where it's essentially wires and space
where essentially the radio energy is
all concentrated in something that is a
very a very definite beam kind of like a
laser for example concentrates light
leads to a decent extent will laser
beams do spread out but you know you
shoot a laser from the earth to the moon
it's several kilometers wide by the time
it gets to the Moon even with sort of
the best laser cavities but in um
in the case where uh so so this this
problem of of um having uh radio energy
that's sort of directed in sort of wires
and space is something we will get
closer and closer to
um and uh it'll be sort of more and more
equivalent to having the data just go
through sort of wires uh you know
explicit wires now an interesting
question is whether when you get to kind
of the infrared light that is used for
for fiber optics
um maybe it's even visible light
sometimes I'm not sure
um but uh uh that because light
you know typical radio waves may be you
know a few gigahertz a few a few billion
cycles per second that allows you to get
data raid transmit data by radio at the
rate of a few billion uh bits per second
um in the case of fiber light that's a
few trillion bits per second
um so there's there's uh significant
um uh significantly more information can
be sent through through uh uh with light
and you can even add more than that
because of the way that you can
Multiplex signals onto onto fibers and
so on but any case the um and to some
extent you can do that on radio as well
but the basic point is an interesting
question is right now we imagine that in
free space transmission of things it's
it's just radio but one could also
Imagine and certainly one does this you
know on a limited extent one could
imagine doing that with you know making
phased array type things with with
infrared
um I think that's something that is not
possible yet but one can imagine that
becoming impossible and then you can
kind of have sort of uh wires in them uh
that are
um
of of higher frequency energy
um and you you know the the distinction
between sending something through a wire
and sending something through free space
will will tend to disappear now of
course the problem with sending
something if you have a wire
it you kind of know it's going to be
able to go from place a to place B
because you've got that physical wire
that is going from place a to place B if
it's in free space then if you happen to
put an obstruction between the the
source and the receiver then oops the
you know you're blocking that
transmission but the whole point is that
that when it is kind of a a kind of a
soft thing that's Computing that's
working out where the beams actually go
you can end up with all kinds of
elaborate things where oh somebody
walked in in the way that means that the
phase duration change its transmission
send it in a different path et cetera et
cetera Etc use the fact that it's going
to bounce off some other object
um and so on and be able to adapt in
real time which is what happens in 5G
and so on
let's see
uh
all right well oh there was a question
about the moon-based radio telescope
yeah I mean I it seems like a good idea
to me I mean it's you can you know the
moon's a very peaceful place where there
are no but you don't have to fight with
anybody at least right now to uh sort of
make a big thing that uh put big thing
all all over The Far Side of the Moon
you could probably have some some great
uh
um long Baseline interferometry of um of
different receiving points in different
places uh it's it's obviously more of a
nuisance to get things to the moon but
um uh once it's there it seems like a
Fine Place to operate a radio telescope
I I don't really know I mean it it
really helps that the Moon
the fast side of the moon is shadowed
relative to the Earth and so the radio
Transmissions from the earth just don't
go there
um and that really helps if you're in
out in I mean in if you go far enough
away from the earth well you'll be away
from the radio transmissions on the
earth so you can have a uh you can have
radio telescope like things that are in
free space so to speak uh certainly for
example gravitational wave detectors
there's a plan to have a satellite-based
gravitational wave detector that is a
bunch of satellites that are sort of
knowing how far apart they are by by
exchanging laser signals and when a
gravitational wave comes through it
distorts the structure of space and the
effective distance apart between these
satellites uh will change even though
it's it will be knowing what their
orbits are so we know how far apart
they're supposed to be but the when a
gravitational wave comes through oops
they're they'll they'll they'll
effectively be further apart because the
structure of space has changed and
that's going to be detectable
you know the question is what's what's
going to be done on the moon and uh it's
always a question you know people say
well let's go to the moon it's it's
interesting it's impressive to go to the
moon but
um we learn a certain amount about
things about the history of the Earth
for example because the moon has been
very untouched relative to the Earth
with its atmosphere and so on so we get
to see you know every piece of rock was
probably an initial piece of rock that's
always been on the moon that's always
been sort of exposed there
um and uh but you know the question of
how do we how do we make use of the Moon
um the the thing I'm hearing most
recently is let's put heavy industry on
the moon uh you know if we've got um all
sorts of uh things that um
produce uh all kinds of uh
um pollutants or whatever else let's not
put those into the Earth's atmosphere
let's kind of vent them out into empty
space from the moon so that's been a um
uh kind of the ultimate Outsourcing
location maybe not ultimate but the next
major sort of Outsourcing location put
the heavy industry on the moon
I don't know how realistic it is I I
think it's actually not unlikely that
that will happen and you know I don't
know what the situation with you know
mining lithium on the moon or something
like that doing the things you need to
make batteries for example uh those are
things where it's um one could imagine
sort of Outsourcing those to the moon
and not muddying up our atmosphere so to
speak because after all on the moon when
something is sort of belched out from
the factory on the moon it's just going
to go into empty space and it'll be uh
sort of uh you know those those
particles from um actually it's an
interesting question what will happen
with them I think it's a question of
whether they are faster than the escape
velocity of the Moon which is 160 escape
velocity of the Earth if you can have
your factory it's producing kind of I
don't know uh well uh let's see I mean
carbon dioxide for example I would
suspect to this yes it obviously does
escape from the Moon because after all
the moon has no atmosphere so all of the
gaseous elements and and compounds uh
their their typical oil actually it's
not so obvious because it depends on the
temperature
um well the question is when you sort of
belch out carbon dioxide from some
process on the moon what happens to
those carbon dioxide molecules my guess
is that in most cases they will escape
the moon's gravity and just get
dissipated uh
um into into space but it is also
possible they just fall back down again
and you talk about carbon uh you know
capture or something and carbon
sequestration it might happen
automatically because the things that um
uh instead of getting kind of enmeshed
with the atmosphere and the air currents
on the earth it would instead just sort
of fall back to the moon it's either
going to fall back or it's just going to
be sort of spewed out into space
um
let's see
uh Kappa asks how would you get the
signal back to Earth from the From The
Far Side of the Moon that's pretty easy
you just have satellites orbiting the
Moon that relay it back it's not quite
as easy as on the earth you know we have
communication satellites on the earth
that are
um
you know able to take uh able to you
know you you send the signal to the
satellite the satellite could perhaps
send the sign to another satellite or it
simply can see another part of the earth
and send that signal down to another
part of the Earth
um but
and that's uh so you can do the exact
same thing on the moon and so if you
have a satellite orbiting high above the
Moon it will be able you could either do
it uh directly or with a relay to
another satellite
um to get the signal from The Far Side
of the Moon Back to the Earth
um the Moon is a little trickier than
the earth to have satellites because its
gravity is not as uniform as the gravity
of the earth uh the and the earth the
earth is not a perfect sphere but it's
pretty close the Moon is is a sphere but
it has a big lump of different density
on one side probably from the way it was
formed and that means that the orbits of
satellites are more complicated and
don't don't end up being a fixed
distance from the Moon as they typically
are roughly on the earth and that means
it's a little bit harder to have a
stable orbit around the Moon
um and uh the thing satellites don't
last in orbit around the Moon and the
Earth the main reason for orbital Decay
and of satellites around the earth it's
just little pieces of atmosphere wisps
of atmosphere that get up pretty high
and that the the tend to slow the
satellite down on the moon there isn't
an issue like that but there is an issue
of the gravity field being a bit messy
um and so more difficult to maintain
something in orbit I I suspect that's a
more of a technical difficulty and that
that by uh you know you might you might
have to use thrusters or something to
arrange that you are going in this
particular path around the moon and and
maybe that's an issue and I don't know
uh you know I don't know I I don't know
whether that can be solved by for
example using essentially electrical ion
thrusters or something like this I'm not
sure
um
Pedro asks
why would so many nations be interested
in the moon well you know partly
realistically it's a it's a good
technology demo send a successful
spacecraft to the moon and you show that
you can successfully assemble a very big
stack of technology to actually get the
thing to land Softly on the moon
um so it's a in terms of kind of
economic development of saying look we
can land a spacecraft on the moon it's
pretty cool to be able to say that and
you know India just just managed to be
able to say that and uh that that you
know is kind of a thing that is a bit of
a a kind of a a um a demo of just like
you know a technology demo so to speak
of capabilities I think that's that's
sort of a number one reason to uh it's a
sort of a driver as the Apollo program
in the US was a big driver of kind of
technical Innovation
um in in many different areas of of
Technology uh that's a that's a good
reason to kind of go to the Moon
but in terms of what's going to be the
kind of economic benefit the direct
economic benefit as opposed to indirect
economic benefit of going to the moon
it's a bit unclear I mean uh you know
there's it's not clear there's much to
mine on the moon except for for example
water for example which can be used for
fuel to send spacecraft further away but
it's kind of like like okay the moon
isn't useful let's let's see if Mars was
useful for example and then the question
is is that something we can get from
Mars and bring back to Earth probably
not I've not really heard of anything
serious there that people talk about I
mean it'll certainly be interesting to
get Martian rocks and we have a few from
meteorites and so on but to get um sort
of uh you know freshly correct collected
Martian Rock will certainly be very
interesting and boy it will be it will
be very cool if there end up being some
kind of microbes that we find in you
know deep in Martian rock or something
like this that are around like uh like
ones on Earth
um I I think you know this is a a rule
space question of sort of how far apart
is kind of different forms of life so to
speak in the universe and my guess is
very very far apart usually unless they
have a common origin but the um uh but
but in any case in in the case of sort
of it's it's a kind of recursive thing
we want
you know we can use the moon in order to
go to Mars well you know then we have to
know why are we going to Mars and
certainly people talk about eventually
sort of colonizing Mars as you know the
backup Earth 2.0 or whatever I don't
know how convincing that is uh because I
do tend to feel that some of the things
that might cause terrible problems on
Earth uh you know the the uh you know
the AI that decided to wipe out the
humans so to speak we can talk about
whether that's realistic or not but
imagine it is realistic
um the uh there's going to be enough
kind of communications traffic that the
kind of super computer virus is going to
wind up on Mars as well it's not going
to be that separated I mean there are
certainly things that um uh you know
there are plenty of issues that would
easily get transported so to speak and
where it isn't the case that oh
different planet you know completely
isolated situation
so
I think the um uh as I say in terms of
indigenous use of the moon so to speak
um certainly there have been things that
are very unexpected things like for
example the lunar laser retro reflector
that was put on the Moon by the Apollo
Astronauts is the way to measure the
distance the moon more accurately than
anything else
um and that has allowed one to verify
things about theories of gravity and so
on that's a pretty cool unexpected use
of the moon so to speak I think the um
uh things like oh can we mine something
from the Moon other than water to make
rocket fuel and bring it back to the
Earth uh I certainly knew of one
initiative where it was like let's get
moon rock just because it'll be cool
like diamonds are cool
um I'm not sure how convincing that is
because Moon Rock isn't as doesn't have
the nice high refractive index that
diamond has that makes it Diamond
Sparkle and so on when they cut a proper
greatly that's not something we know
particularly how to do for Moon Rock
then there was sort of a possibility
that helium-3 could be mined on the moon
I don't think that's particularly
interesting or realistic
um but I don't know it's it's an
interesting question what becomes
possible maybe there are things that in
one sixth gravity that we have on the
moon there are things that suddenly
become possible that aren't possible in
Earth gravity
um there are definitely things people
talk about in microgravity in in uh in
orbital around the earth things like
growing perfect crystals things like oh
all sorts of well biological processes
are rather different when you don't have
gravity
um so there are there are questions
there but you know as is typical of
Technology and Engineering given a thing
that physics throws at us the question
is can we find a way to make use of it
and if you say okay you can build
anything you want in one sixth gravity
is there a great way to make use of that
I don't know if you can sort of build
anything you want sort of in a way where
you can spew out any kind of uh kind of
um uh sort of output
then there may be a way to make use of
that
all right let me see uh I had some other
questions here
um
well let me go but down here
uh desks
comments suppose we just got lucky and
developed our current technology during
a period of unusual solar calm how do we
adapt if we expect solar storms to cause
Havoc with our Electronics say every few
decades so just a bit of background
there the the Sun
uh produces
um streams of charge particles and in
addition to producing light the sun
produces the solar wind and you know
every day you can look it up and move
now for if you type uh space weather
into wolfen Alpha you'll see uh kind of
today's space weather which is kind of
what's coming from the Sun today not in
the form of light in the form of charged
particles and every so often there's a
major solar flare that spews a huge
number of charged particles in the
direction of the Earth for example and
that happened particularly dramatically
in 1859 I think of the Carrington event
um where uh if that happened today it
would uh sort of create Havoc with a lot
of electronics
um on the earth essentially what's
happening is that the these charged
particles as they kind of um uh they
will induce currents in um uh in wires
and that will cause things that are set
up like electronics that is set up to
operate in particular voltage uh
basically
most most computer type Electronics
ultimately operates around six volts why
is that it's because in Silicon the
which is the the thing used for
microprocessors and so on these days
universally the uh the way it works is
there's a critical thing the so-called
band gap of silicon which is how much
you have to kick electrons that are
otherwise hanging around silicon atoms
how if you kick the electrons that are
hanging around silicon atoms with a six
volt kick basically then they get to the
point where they get into a conduction
band where essentially those electrons
can freely roam around the Silicon
around the the salt and Crystal and so
there's this there's this kind of a lot
of the operation of electronics is
relies on this kind of ability to go
from and it's a complicated story with
doping with other materials that changes
how that works and that's how you make
transistors and so on but in general
terms six volts is the critical voltage
that kind of promotes electrons from
being you know stuck around the silicon
atom to being able to roam freely well
so if you put 100 volts into that piece
of electronics it'll you know wreak
havoc with the whole thing because all
those electrons will get promoted
they'll all there'll be conduction
between everything it'll all be a big
mess
so it's bad to do that and if you have
something where you induce those kinds
of voltages induce currents induce
voltages
um you can destroy the electronics
um and that's that's bad so
you know that could happen
um and we would have some warning of it
we have I think well you know light
comes from the sun in eight minutes to
the Earth and there are telescopes
watching the Sun and if there was a
giant solar flare we would see it long
before eight minutes before the child
but it's actually longer than that
because the charged particles and the
eight minutes is actually irrelevant the
the eight minutes is how long it takes
light to come from the sun we don't even
know anything happened on the sun until
in a sense eight minutes after it
happened but the question of what counts
as simultaneity is a whole relativity
story which we don't have to worry about
here what matters more is that the
charge particles are going much slower
than the speed of light I think they
take a day or something to get to the
Earth from the Sun and and so if we see
something happened on the sun we have a
fair amount of warning about the fact
that there is a a coming you know burst
of charged particles that can mess up
our Electronics I have to admit I don't
completely know what like I I don't
think I I know of sort of what the
arrangements are like like does you know
what will actually happen in the world
if there's another one of these events
that is seen
um and we have a day's warning I I would
assume that things like planes uh will
not happily fly in that situation and
that presumably but I don't know how the
arrangements are set up you know all the
planes would get grounded and the other
big thing is that
um uh long distance electrical
transmission lines get big voltages
induced in them and so you can do things
like blow up electrical Transformers and
so on and I don't really know other than
shutting down the power grid I'm not
quite sure what you do about that and
even if you shut down the power grid
you're still inducing currents which
which will have bad effects but I'm sure
there are things that can be done to
remediate that but I have no idea
whether you know 1859 was a long time
ago and so people have kind of Forgotten
what happened then
um and obviously the world was uh much
less electrified at that time than it is
today
uh now the question is if this happens
regularly what does one do about it
um I think that uh their
there will be certain aspects of what's
going on
um
um that um
uh
you know it it's kind of like
um
you know I don't know how much effect it
will have on kind of the actual way
things do people ways people do things I
mean if there's if there's one big event
every decade every 30 years
and it's kind of like well if you have a
satellite TV and it's raining and you
don't get the good signal well so be it
but the rain will be over eventually
um and uh you know there are things like
that where one can say well some things
are going to have to I mean you know
there are outages that happen and maybe
this is just a a an outage that happens
for a limited period of time I don't
think it's something that lasts terribly
long Harry is commenting there's an
International Alert system for solar
activity you can subscribe to it okay
well I'm guessing there must be
something like that because we have
space weather data in open language so
worst case you could write it there to
say if the density of charged particles
is greater than this send you a text
message or something
um I think
that um
um I was going to say in terms of sort
of early warning type stuff there are
places where earthquakes for example uh
there's a fault line earthquakes happen
at the fault line the central population
is some distance away and there's an
early warning system that's been set up
for uh you know because the earthquake
you that you detect the earthquake and
the earthquake the sort of effect of the
earthquake moves through seismic waves
which travel at a few thousand miles per
hour
um much slower than uh the speed of
light much slower than the time it takes
to send a signal through radio or
through fiber optic cables and things uh
to some place and I I know there are you
know factories shut down and all kinds
of other things happen even if there's
only a few minutes of uh of warning
that's that's a good thing and obviously
in things like tsunamis there's now
um a it was for a long time a Pacific
tsunami early warning system which
actually made use of our technology I
happen to know and uh now I think there
are ones for all oceans a similar kind
of thing
well let's see uh
ah prototype comments fiber optics have
reduced our vulnerability to solar
storms I'm sure that's true where where
all the landlines were copper
um only the power grid remains they say
uh that that sounds that sounds
plausible
um I think the um uh and no doubt if
everybody has their very own solar
panels and things or their very own
local you know Fusion reactor or
whatever it is then um uh you know these
long distance uh lines I guess the
I mean my impression is I I should know
this piece of physics but um uh
there's a certain
what would it be an induced voltage
that a per unit length of wire
um has some effect and I don't know uh
um
I don't know I I'm certainly aware of
the fact that something I don't know how
comparable it is the electromagnetic
pulse that you get from detonation of a
nuclear weapon in space
um that affects even small scale
um
uh low voltage electronics and I I don't
know how similar that is to the induced
currents that come from solar activity
uh I must be somewhat similar because
it's it's again it's
a
hmm
well I yeah I'm not sure not sure
physics to work out there
um
all right let's see other
questions well okay Jamie asks what does
the future look like for computational
language will it be adopted on a larger
scale
well building computational language
embodied in our welcome language is my
kind of Life work trying to find ways to
represent our world computationally
trying to find ways to essentially
formalize how things in the world work
going from kind of what we can just
describe for example a natural language
to things that we can describe more
formally as we have been able to do in
mathematics in logic and so on
generalizing that to sort of having a
computational description of the world
that's kind of been my life work and and
the last well 35 years we've been
working for 36 years we've been working
on both language to let people be able
to make those kinds of computational
descriptions of the world and then to
sort of automate doing things with those
computational descriptions of the world
and you know in the in the world of
people doing research development
education and so on the whole idea of
computational language I think has been
uh well in particular cases has been
quite well absorbed
um and I think it's generally true that
having this computational description of
the world that's that has a lot of
knowledge built into it a lot of
algorithms built into it
um a lot of coherence and the different
ways that that things are treated in
different parts of the computational
language that's a critical idea for
people who are doing things that have
never been done before
um that's kind of you know if you look
at the history of the last 35 years of
things that people have used
mathematical language for a really
pretty impressive swath of things that
have been invented in the world
discovered in the world
um have made use of of that technology
and it is really sort of the ideal
technology for doing things that have
never been done before
now you know if you look at sort of the
the rank and file of software
engineering much less use of Orphan
language than there should be much much
less use and it's it's an interesting
question why and the I think I I've sort
of realized that one of the issues is
the following if you use some low-level
language you know I don't know Java
python whatever C plus plus whatever it
is
there's there's a fair amount of just
mechanical work that you end up doing
just building things with that language
the language doesn't have much built in
it's you know maybe you get some Library
you get from here to there you move
Cobble This Together Etc et cetera et
cetera it doesn't you have to do a lot
of sort of mechanical work to get to the
particular things you want
whereas in Northern language we've we've
built everything in that's kind of the
idea and so what you are presented with
is a okay what do you want to do once
you can Define what you want to do the
Machinery of doing it is rather
straightforward typically it is but you
are uh you know if you're doing
something in some little language it's
like well I'm figuring out what I'm
going to do that takes me a day
maybe if you can be good at figuring it
out then you spend the next two months
implementing that
whereas and and much of in those two
months are just like you show up every
day you write your code you go home well
maybe you're writing it at home these
days but but um uh you know it's it's a
it's a pretty procedural kind of thing
and sort of the the duty cycle for the
the thinking part is a much smaller part
now people are realizing that with llms
and so on you can write a lot of that
boilerplate code I don't know how
reliably that's an issue we're still
trying to understand that better but uh
you can write at least some of that
boilerplate code some of that kind of
Mechanical Code can get written by an AI
and so the humans don't need to do it
anymore and that's again beginning to
sort of crunch things up to the point
that is more like the story with
computational language where it's kind
of mostly thinking and not so much
mechanical work
and so the thing that is sort of perhaps
uh well to the people who kind of do new
things in the world it's a uh it's
something that well they just want to go
as fast as they can and they're in the
in the business of figuring out new
thoughts and figuring out how to do new
things in the world and so for them
having the tools that make it as easy as
possible to go from the thought to the
implementation is just a huge win and
that's kind of the Story of My Life in
science and so on is using wolfen
language as a tool to be able to do a
lot of things like our physics project
and so on that would just have been
completely infeasible impossible would
never have happened without that level
of Automation and actually getting the
mechanics of doing of doing the
technology uh done so to speak so we're
we're kind of in the situation where
where with wolf language with
computational language in general it's
sort of all thinking about what to do
and not so much effort in the doing of
it because that's what we've automated
away
and in a sense that becomes something
kind of daunting if you're not in the
business of figuring out what to do so
to speak uh and I think that's that's
kind of the number one reason why you
don't see as much kind of uh sort of use
of computational language maybe it's
also because we haven't marketed as well
as we should have done but I think the
the more underlying reason is because an
awful lot of the activity of programming
is this kind of procedural kind of
activity that uh doesn't you know that
isn't intense concentrated thinking
about what to do and the set of people
who do that into concentrated thinking
about what to do is a bit smaller than
the set of people who need to be there
doing the mechanics of software
engineering so to speak so I think this
is this is kind of the challenge and you
know could many things run faster do
better be more efficient if
computational language was more widely
used absolutely unquestionably and
companies in other organizations sort of
thinking about things in computational
terms how do you take those things that
you're doing in your organization and
how do you think about them as you know
functions that you can apply how do you
think about sort of symbolic data
structures how do you represent the
things you sell as symbolic Expressions
that then are a kind of computational
representation of the actual things you
sell and so on which you can then
manipulate deal with in your transaction
processing system whatever else these
are things where sort of defining how to
think about things computationally
that's the main stumbling block and once
you can unders once you understand
things with Clarity if if we and I have
done a good job in designing wolfen
language and we've done a good job in
implementing sort of the the
computational knowledge that's inside it
then then really once you've figured out
how to express yourself how to think
about something computationally then
it's plain sailing then then it's just
then it's sort of turning the idea into
reality is a straightforward part the
difficult part is conceptualizing the
idea and so I think that's the main sort
of Blocker in a sense and I don't know
what you know I have to say I think that
the unlocking of of progress if
more was done where it goes from idea to
reality that the the removal of barriers
and going from ideas to reality that
computational language provides are
tremendous I mean as again you know I I
pre you know I I myself am I'm uh have
been pleased to be an example of what's
possible there and what one can actually
achieve in most cases in my case in
science
um by making use of those uh uh that
that the capabilities of computational
language there's a huge amount that will
be unlocked now how do we get there from
here
you know I think that one of the primary
problems is is having people understand
how to think about things
computationally I I plan to do a project
hopefully starting very soon to create
some kind of book course I don't know
what probably live streams and things as
well sort of explaining this process how
do you think about the world
computationally you know I've been doing
this for 40 something years and then
different sort of corners of the world
and different kinds of things you do
there are different ways to sort of
think about things computationally once
people understand that with Clarity then
there's sort of every chance to be able
to you know given the actual technology
we built a lot of things get to run a
lot faster
it's left to its own devices I don't
know how long it will take for people to
get to the point of sort of uh widely
adopting this I mean as I say it's been
adopted very widely among people who are
figuring out and doing things for the
first time and sort of the high end of
research and development I it's always
remarkable to me it's very satisfying in
a sense that when I'm talking to people
and it turns out they did something sort
of that's a major piece of sort of
research and development 10 years ago
let's say it's like oh by the way they
use welcome language to do that
um it's there's a tremendous correlation
between the things that really are
things done for the first time in the
world and uh in terms of r d and places
where orphan language has been used it's
it's really that's it's uh sort of the
the the most incisive part of its that's
contribution I would say but
you know if you look at the time scales
for adoption of things where people sort
of generally understand oh this is how
things work they are shockingly long I
mean even the idea of notebooks for
example which we invented in 1987 took
at least 25 years for people outside of
our technology ecosystem to really say
oh yeah this is a good idea I mean I
remember 25 years earlier people were
saying I don't understand I don't
understand what is this and you know 25
years later that really very very very
straightforward idea
um becomes something that is uh is more
widely uh you know absorbed I think
there are a lot of ideas in the kind of
symbolic programming domain that were
core ideas in Mathematica in our world
from language and even in the my
predecessor to these things SMP that I
built in 1979 to 1981
um that was uh there are a lot of ideas
about symbolic programming that are
completely not widely absorbed
um and uh as I say people who know and
use both language uh either implicitly
or explicitly understand many of those
ideas but if we look at the things
Beyond those core ideas if you look at
kind of the the Tower of ideas that
we've managed to build it's a pretty big
tower and many of those ideas once you
know once you understand how to think
about things computationally many of
those ideas are very natural and easy to
use
um but kind of the the kind of absorbing
those things and absorbing the whole
sort of computational thinking idea I
don't know how long it's going to take I
think you know I think the time scales
are measured in the century half century
I don't know century is probably time
scales if if kind of left to their own
devices I think this is one of our
challenges in modern times is to
communicate
sort of how to think about things
computationally and as the Machinery to
do that kind of the uh we have of
language I mean it's just like when
people started thinking about things
mathematically it was critical to have
mathematical notation as a way to
express those mathematical ideas the
point of computational language in both
language is to have a way to express
ideas computationally so that you can
kind of go forward and have a medium for
thinking about things computationally
it's kind of the uh you know people
often say it's hard to think about
things unless you have words for them
and this is our computational language
is the kind of medium in which I think
one can think about things
computationally and I think that's
that's just the thing that has to be
learned is how do you think about things
computationally it's like most people
would not invent either logic or
mathematics for themselves in fact I
think almost nobody would
um those are things that have Arisen and
our civilization and through long
periods of time and the things that you
have to sort of learn in education and
so it is with computational thinking and
computational language but unfortunately
to date there's there's very scant
education in that area there's there's
plenty of Education nowadays in quotes
computer science which often means the
practicalities of programming and to
some extent some of the very wonderful
and interesting theory that goes along
with all of that but in terms of okay
you've got this thing let's think about
it computationally that's not something
for which there is a well understood
kind of educational path and I guess it
looks like it's falling on me to try and
figure out how to build that
so uh
let's see
um
question here
from robot asking how do you anticipate
biotechnology shaping the future of
biomaterials and tissue engineering
oh gosh well
you know if you want to make
I don't know a piece of heart muscle
there's kind of several ways you might
imagine doing it
one thing you might imagine doing is
getting a stem cell
you know one of the things was
discovered maybe what was it 10 15 years
ago is how to take any old cell and hit
it with these funny
um
uh it's kind of almost frankensteinian
kind of mechanism you know you're kind
of hitting it with these particular
molecules and so on and you are getting
it to revert to a state where you're
kind of cleaning its DNA to the point
where it is able to be a pluripotent
stem cell a stem cell that can turn into
any other kind of cell so you know
strategy number one would be you go you
take a cell from a person you kind of
want to sell from the same person
because otherwise their immune system
otherwise if it's a foreign cell so to
speak the immune system of the person
will reject it but if you take a cell
from the same person and you say uh you
know you hit it with these these
chemicals you get it to revert to its uh
sort of initial stem cell State and then
you guide it through the differentiation
Pathways to get to the type of cell you
want
and I think there's sort of a lot of art
involved in doing that guiding and some
of it requires that the cell being an
environment that's kind of like the
environment it would be in in a natural
growing organism but you know at most
there are perhaps 15 differentiation
events to get to any of the types of
cells of the few thousand cell types
that are part of us you can potentially
do that by having the cell kind of go in
the right way at those different sort of
Choice points for the cellular
differentiation so that's kind of one
thing you can do is make individual
cells by by that mechanism the other
thing you can do is try and make sort of
scaffolding and and that's a thing that
um uh people are interested in trying to
do like I've seen a very nice example of
uh uh artificial lung that's being 3D
printed by just making a material that
is like the the the
um
uh collagen that um yeah that's the
that's kind of the skeleton of something
like a lung you build up that framework
in something that is not really cells
that are doing the things that living
cells do you build that framework by
essentially a very high resolution 3D
printing and then you kind of coat it
with the kinds of things that um uh
sells that sort of do other things in
the long do so it's kind of this
trade-off of you are making a thing
where you you're 3D printing the
scaffolding and then you put it putting
cells onto that scaffolding versus the
other case where you're making
individual cells and the Assembly of
those individual cells into larger Kinds
of Kinds of assemblies I'm not I'm not
um
I'm not quite sure what the what the
right way to do that is I mean you know
that's been a thing that people have
encountered and for example making
artificial meat
um is like how do you create this kind
of whole Matrix how do you create this
whole thing where it's not just
individual uh fibroblast muscle cells
but it's a whole sort of assembly of
those things
um in the in the form that is that they
would exist in an actual uh you know
piece of meat basically
um and I think uh so that that's that's
on one scale I mean I think that the
other
the other important level for
biotechnology is sort of cells think
molecules and cells that do things you
know most you know drugs for example
their main mechanism of action is
they're a molecule they're a certain
shape they fit into some binding site on
some other molecule and they make more
of something happen or less of something
happen but the molecules just this it's
just like a puzzle piece it's not it's
not doing anything it's it's just
fitting into something so one can
imagine a situation where the actual
molecule is capable of doing
computations or where it's a whole cell
and where the whole cell takes certain
inputs kind of decides what to do and
then takes action now you know like many
things we didn't think of this you know
this has been thought of by biology
before that's how the immune system
works you know a T cell in the immune
system is essentially we don't know all
the details of it but is doing all kinds
of things interacting with other T cells
interacting with various kinds of uh uh
I don't know cytokines and other other
kinds of molecules and so on and then
making a decision oh that's a bad cell I
should go kill it or whatever else and
being able to make sort of an artificial
version of that is another whole sort of
story of what becomes possible in in um
in biotechnology
so I mean a few thoughts there on on
that I think that um
in
you know that's sort of the question of
to what extent are you getting something
which is functionally equivalent to
biology let's say you're trying to make
artificial blood that's been a long time
story you know right now our blood uses
hemoglobin A protein that has this
little cage that's just the right size
to fit an iron atom in that and that
iron atom can have oxygen uh uh bound to
it and so you can transport oxygen
around your bloodstream but it's like
well why can't we just make a uh you
know make our own hemoglobin-like thing
make our own red blood cell and
transport oxygen around uh around us and
that hasn't been successfully done but
that's sort of one branch is to say well
let's just make something which is
functionally equivalent to biology but
it's not made from the same stuff that
biology is made from not not made from
proteins for example just a purely uh
you know like a 3D printed blood red
blood cell or something that just
functionally is equivalent to red blood
cell rather than being like the living
material that we have
and uh so you know that's that's one
branch the other branches kind of go
from stem cells and build up something
which really is just like a piece of you
so to speak
um that uh
uh that that can that can do that I
think one thing that is is interesting
is kind of to what extent you know we
managed to make all the stuff we need
um but as we get older for example more
of it stops working properly and there's
sort of a question what actually changed
and there's a lot of evidence now that
quite a lot of what changed is sort of
things that are epigenetic things that
sort of are attached to the DNA that in
our cells but they don't change the The
genome at least not unless we get cancer
and things they don't change the genome
um they just are changing sort of the
the the the dressing around the genome
and so this with the fact that it's
possible to go get back to stem cells
that you can go and uh sort of uh
introduce these factors that that let
you go uh sort of revert back from a
differentiated cell that has sort of
dressing around its DNA to one that is
sort of a pure stem cell makes one think
well maybe if there's more dressing that
gets developed as a result of things
getting older and and crummier so to
speak maybe one can go backwards by just
using the same kind of method now you
know that would all be just perfect were
it not for the fact that as soon as you
have a silicon differentiate into
anything one of the things that can
differentiate into is a tumor and
um and that's bad because the tumor then
grows without a bound and eventually
takes over other functions of the body I
mean in a sense you know one of the
achievements of biological life back
probably 1.52 billion years ago was
being able to make life that grows only
so big and then stops and what had
happened earlier than that is things
well these stromatolites and things like
that just growing growing growing
growing you know huge areas
um where there's just a single thing
that just keeps on keeps on keeps on
growing but then it turned out that
Evolution found it better to have
individual organisms that got to a
limited size and um uh were sort of
independent organisms not quite sure
what the advantage of that is but but I
suppose there's more sort of it's like
it's it's a actually it's sort of a
discretization Play Just Like a sort of
interesting point that that biological
evolution discovered the idea of
discrete organisms rather than just the
continuous one organism is all of life
so to speak that it's better to have uh
many eggs or many baskets for your eggs
so to speak rather than just putting
everything into one organism it's better
to have many separate organisms running
around that can independently succeed
and fail rather than putting everything
into that one organism which maybe maybe
all fails for some reason
so
in any case the um but that's sort of
the main issue is that you can end up
with with cells that will just uh go
back to that primitive form of life and
you know keep replicating Forever
Without uh without sort of knowing
limits and without noticing oh you know
we've managed to grow this particular
muscle and it's now filled this area now
stop so to speak rather than just
keeping on growing
let's see
uh
so many interesting questions here
um
uh
maybe one or two more and then I need to
go back to
some
science that I need to do today
um
uh
well cut asks how do you see the future
of information consumption will it all
be digital Well Physical books still be
relevant will it even be reading or
simply data trips inserted into the
brain
so a thing to realize is sort of relates
to the very abstract stuff I was talking
about earlier all of us encode
information internally in our brains in
somewhat different ways
if you took
the very nerve you know the the pattern
of weights and the neural net that in my
brain and transplanted it to another
brain it will be completely useless
because that other brain will encode
information in a different way in detail
so the only way we know to get
information from one brain to another is
by packaging it up into Concepts words
language and so on and having it
unpacked in the other brain now it could
be that as we have you know direct
neural connections to brains
that we will be able to learn a
translation layer for each given brain
which does at least something to
transmit ideas directly into the form
appropriate for the brain in which that
neural implant exists and that's
certainly a possibility but I think
otherwise we're stuck with sort of
packaging information in in any
situation we're still packaging the
information for the neural implant for
our eyes whatever we're packaging
information in a uniform way that kind
of is a is a language that everybody can
understand whether it's human language
computational language whatever else
um now
I mean it is an interesting question
whether we can directly feed
computational language to human brains
it doesn't work in our neural Nets we
can't run programs in our minds but if
we had a sort of a direct connection to
something that can run a program a
direct kind of neural implant with woven
language or something then uh you know
what does that mean what would that feel
like to us it would be kind of like uh
it would probably feel very much like
many aspects of our existence that we
don't have conscious control over feel
it's kind of like uh I don't know you
have a reflex for example you know you
you know pit just below your kneecap and
you're in your in your leg you know
bounces out from that reflex
um you can override that reflex but but
you can't you know you can't there's
nothing where you're you're thinking to
yourself now I'm going to kick my leg
out type thing and I think what it would
feel like if you have the sort of neural
implant that does computational language
I think it would feel like
essentially just I'm thinking this
thought and then suddenly something
happens and it happens sort of
automatically and I didn't have to think
that in order to have that thing be the
next thought I think I suspect this
happens
um
you know we don't get to unpack our
thoughts most of the time in other words
when somebody says why did you come up
with that
well you can kind of reverse engineer
something to say but really it just
popped into your mind it wasn't
something where you can where you felt
the steps so to speak and maybe that's
how it will feel with sort of a neural
implant kind of thing
in terms of the absorption of
information see one of the things that
happens right now like
I much prefer written printed
you know visual diagram type information
to videos why is that it's because I
have control over what part of the
information I am absorbing like I can
skim through to the next page whereas
with a video it's kind of like unlocked
in to absorb what was presented so to
speak
so
I think in you know if you ask a
question will there be sort of
information provided uh
um
you know it's actually interesting that
I think even books for example which
seem very Antiquated in a sense for uh
are still very useful because books
represent a certain unit of information
transmission that
is and it has a certain expectation of
organization in a book that's different
from the arbitrarily scrolling linked
you know kind of uh tree of web pages or
something it's it's a humanly useful
thing it's kind of like you could say
well
uh you know we could make things for us
humans we could make
um uh sort of I don't know roller skates
that move humans around at 100 miles an
hour or something but it wouldn't work
for humans humans wouldn't be able to
deal with that that's not something
that's a good fit for humans and so I
think you know when it comes to
information there's a question of how do
you how do you form the information in a
way that is readily absorbed by humans
and and even things like books turn out
to be a good form for absorbing
information and when you've gradually
learned different forms whether they're
blogs or whether they're bullet points
or whatever we we've gradually learned
the kind of ergonomics of good ways to
present information
now I suspect that one of the things
that llms
will be able to do is help us to have
information both
generically presented effectively I mean
like I routinely have llms you know
summarize abstracts of papers so I can
just see well what's the two sentence
summary in kind of the the somewhat
boring text produced Naturally by 911
and that's useful for me it's easier to
absorb that than the longer abstracts
and so on that we might have
so
that's a um uh uh you know that and as
we you know personalizing that
absorption of information I think is
something quite realistic where the llm
knows what I know and knows that the
thing you need to say to me to get me to
understand this particular new point is
this particular thing and to somebody
different you might have to say a
different thing so I kind of think that
it is quite likely that one will get to
the point where it's like there's this
piece of information and then your pet
llm kind of is your tutor that explains
that thing to you so it's more so that
instead of reading the raw thing you're
more kind of okay tell me what this says
I mean I have to admit that in my life
and times of somebody who is doing lots
of stuff and Running Company and things
like that uh you know there are plenty
of times where I will say here's this
thing I'm trying to absorb the
information from it and I'll ask another
person can you read this in detail and
summarize it for me in a way that that I
might understand I think that will
become more and more automatically
possible with llms and so on
all right maybe one last question and
then we should wrap up here
uh
okay Ole asks is a fun one will we ever
get to the point of other mammals
evolving into the intelligence level of
humans
um
you know we don't know what the
civilization of the whales is like
it isn't like human civilization
it's you know we hear Wales songs and
they have all kinds of complicated
structure we don't understand what the
whales are saying and so I don't think
we really know what the quotes level of
intelligence whatever that might mean of
the Wales is right now even right now
I mean they certainly haven't built
technology the same way we built
technology they uh if that is our
measure of progress and intelligence
then we're the we're the winners but you
know perhaps
to the whales there's a quite different
measure of progress which uh for which
we humans are like oh I can't believe
you guys don't understand you know the
whales would be saying I can't believe
you guys don't understand the elaborate
way that information is stored and
currents in the ocean and the way that
uh one can have sort of a a uh a global
friend Network because sound gets
transmitted easily across the ocean the
way that one you know that that we have
this form of social organization the
Wales might say in which sort of
everything everybody is cooperating on
everything how come you humans don't
have that how come it's all kind of
broken into these small pieces and you
have to kind of assemble it into
governments and things like this we
whales don't need any of that we're much
smarter than that type of thing so I
don't think I don't think we know yet
um what exists there but in terms of
evolving a technological civilization
for example of the kind that we humans
have I mean in insofar as
what are the drivers of evolution we
don't really know what the driver of
evolution for us humans was maybe it was
even you know at the critical right
moment you know climate change that
caused us to have to get our act
together
um and led to inventing language and and
uh having you know better uh you know
better hands and and all this kind of
thing and and not being in the trees and
who knows what else you know maybe there
was some constraint on us that forced us
to get smarter in some sense
uh the question is is that same forcing
function going to exist for um
wrong animals I think an interesting
question is pets and whether there is a
driver of evolution for pets that might
even be the result of artificial
selection instead of natural selection
um and then certainly in terms of
breeding the you know cute looking
Critters with nice fur all that kind of
thing and maybe breeding them for you
know the the smarter dog or cat or
whatever it is maybe there's some
Dynamic of that you know how far one has
to go let's say an interesting question
I suppose let's say we were breeding
let's say cats for intelligence which I
don't think is something that's really
been done and I I think you know you can
imagine a a way of doing artificial
selection of just you know you've got a
bunch of cats you give them IQ tests of
cat IQ tests of some kind I don't really
believe in human IQ tests but the cat IQ
tests uh you can imagine making a thing
and um you know you pick the smartest
cat in the bunch and that's the one you
mate with another cat maybe we could
Advance the at least the performance of
cats on IQ tests that way I don't think
anybody's ever tried to do that and um
uh you know maybe the question is at
what points do we reach a threshold
where the cats that we have evolved in
that case with our official selection
um you know because maybe the natural
selection of cats is not for the smarter
cats I mean in other words it could be
the case that the the the cat that gets
to have the most kittens is the one that
is you know has the has the longest
claws and that is not a trait so you
will select for that trait but that
trait is not a trait that leads you in
the direction of building a
technological civilization
um that's the trait that leads you in
the direction of being able to Claw at
things better
um you know very different kind of thing
so a question would be if you if you
bred cats let's say for intelligence and
you just kept iterating that for a while
what would what would happen and would
you suddenly get above a threshold where
the cats are starting to you know figure
out how to talk and starting to be able
to um uh you know
to start building things with their paws
and all this kind of stuff I don't know
I don't think anybody knows
um I think that we've seen a very
interesting example in recent times with
the emergence of chat GPT where they're
with language models that were
progressively getting better but they
were still really pretty crummy by human
standards and then suddenly we get above
this threshold where people say wow this
is writing human-like text so maybe the
same thing happens with uh cat spread
for intelligence that for you know 500
Generations nothing much happens and
then suddenly it's a wow my cat is
talking to me type thing I'm not sure
that will be certainly an interesting
thing to think about trying I'm not sure
what how one feels about doing that I
mean the ethics of doing that are rather
complicated
um and especially if one could reach
kind of uh you know what would it mean
if we if we reached kind of uh sort of
visible to humans level cognitive
capabilities for cats and we'd we kind
of have to decide you know are we are we
going to have sort of human
exceptionalism or are we going to sort
of seed part of the planet to the cats
um the uh uh Harry comets that their
guesses the cats have just become even
better at training their supposed
Masters yeah that's a that's a cute
comment I mean it's kind of like the AIS
we we progressively get um uh
um
uh you know we we progressively we think
we're training the AIS but it's a common
feature of people who design computer
and interfaces that it's easier to train
the humans implicitly in using the
computer interface than it is to have
the human the user interface adapt I
mean it's a very common kind of joke in
this area that you know people say well
we have this adaptive interface actually
it turns out it doesn't adapt at all the
only thing that adapts is the people
using it
so
um I think uh
uh some comments about cat GPT yeah
that's a that's a that's a nice thing I
you know it's a thing a number of people
are doing experiments right now on using
kind of large language models for things
like Wales and so on and what can one do
from that but it's a little bit
difficult because we don't really know
how to associate kind of the Wales song
with what that represents what the
meaning of that is we have a sense
because we get to have an internal view
of human Minds we get to have an
internal sense of what meaning of things
is
um the uh
yeah I think that um this question of um
uh I mean my guess is
that um uh there isn't enough of a
driver
for uh
uh you know in the current state of the
world
um
the
um we humans are in charge enough that
there isn't enough of a driver for uh
sort of uh the the
up intelligencing of other species so to
speak
um for that to happen by natural
selection but it certainly Could Happen
by artificial selection and oh boy the
consequence of that I mean there are so
many of these very complicated ethical
issues I mean whether it's um you know
you talk about Ai and you talk about you
know can you switch off an AI is that a
problem
um and you say well it's a computer who
cares it doesn't feel anything but then
you say well maybe that computer is
actually a neural net that is not a
digital electronics neural net it's an
organoid that's been growing with human
nerve cells do you feel differently
about switching it off do you feel
differently about kind of throwing it in
the trash or whatever well I don't know
it's complicated and that's you know
there are a whole collection of these
kind of uh uh or almost sort of
transhuman ethical dilemmas that um uh
we haven't had to address yet
and I don't know whether we have a great
framework for thinking about how to
address them
anyway uh
with that said I'm not yet
um
seeding my role here to to a cat
um and uh but I have to go and do
something else
um so well thanks thanks so much for
joining me thanks for a lot of
interesting questions and comments and
um I look forward to uh continuing this
um the next one of these Q A's and um
thanks to somebody for asking about
computational language and um you know I
do have to say that um uh uh you know
it's look
if you don't know our Tech you should
learn our Tech it's the future even if
in by natural causes it might be 100
years in the future but if you can
deliver that to today it's pretty cool
to get that sort of artifact from the
future and uh make use of it today so
something to be encouraged and um also
uh helps us make a living and uh do more
r d and make more interesting things
so okay well thanks very much and bye
for now